European Union regulations with bans
over 1600 chemicals this whole idea that
EU products are safer because their
bammal stuff really bothers me because
it's just not true unsafe products are
banned in the US including if they have
unsafe levels of anything it's called
adulterated U.S law has a list of 11
ingredient categories that are
explicitly banned but this isn't meant
to be everything these are just examples
Euless also isn't meant to include
everything they've just got more
examples and their list includes a whole
bunch of things that no one would ever
intentionally put into Cosmetics like
radioactive substances there are lots of
examples of the FDA saying that unsafe
products are illegal because they
contain unsafe levels of something that
wasn't on that list of 11. so for
example these products had harmful
levels of bacteria or mold